ask yourself this question what is a
republican platform going to this
campaign no no i'm not i'm in deadly
earnest i'm not trying to be politic
just just a fact i have a couple ideas
here that could be related to the
republican platform how about lowering
gas prices can all benefit from the gas
savings of driving an eevee lowering
inflation look fat look here's the deal
avoiding nuclear war that seems like a
good one to start rich it's a start how
about having a border are we allowed to
do that how about teaching kids not to
hate each other by race you're asking
too much i got another one for you how
about not sexualizing children what am i
looking at
i thought that one was pretty obvious
don't you try and take that away from me
how about permitting kids to go to
school then finally i would say how
about letting people say and believe
what they want online so i would say
those are all republican principles
sounds a little
extreme it doesn't mean the republicans
are great it doesn't mean they always
live up to those principles but it's a
hell of a lot better than what the
democrats are doing